we're not going to be lectured on
morality and toughness by by Andrew Tate
whose great idea of toughness and
morality is pimping women this has Ben
Shapiro last night on uh Piers Morgan he
was on Piers Morgan right yeah it's on
Piers Morgan uh and he talks about his
spat with Tate and and basically just
blows this whole thing apart how did you
engage with him what do you feel about
that well what I feel about that is that
he was tweeting that immediately like as
terrorists were still running around in
southern Israel that was on October 10th
and he was still Tweeting while the
bodies were fresh and warm in the
streets peace is you cannot make peace
with people who murdered your children
and burned their bodies you can't do
that I mean this this rush to Israel I
the murder happens and you immediately
say okay well guys now truce now truce
now ceasefire that is not no State worth
it salt no government on Earth would
allow this kind of insanity no
government on Earth and no government on
Earth would listen to nonsense about how
you immediately have to seek peace with
a group that seeks your direct
extermination again I I can't enough
Israel turned over the Gaza Strip to
gazin in 2005 Hamas has governed the
area since 2006 the year is currently
2023 Israel has has en endured round
after round of Rocket fire on its major
cities for literally almost 20 years and
now the idea is the minute that gazin
that that Gaz and terrorists rush
through the border and murder people in
their beds that's the Time For Peace
conversation that's the Time For Peace
conversation by the way and I'm not
going to be lectured on morality and
toughness by by Andrew Tate whose great
idea of toughness and morality is
pimping women and then bragging about it
on
air all right I know there's nothing
funny about any of this but you know I
got dressed today before I watched that
clip and Ben and I happened to be
dressed exactly the same way today I
don't know if that's if that's God
talking hey I'd like you guys defending
me to wear a blue shirt and a light gray
jacket or something of course everything
he said there is true and that he should
not be lectured about morality or
anything
else